MUELLER LET US DOWN.
>> Sean: JOHN SOLOMON, GREAT
REPORT.
I TWEETED IT OUT.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE
REACTION, REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN.
HE WATCHED THE EVENTS UNFOLD
TODAY AND YOU JUST HEARD JOHN'S
REPORT.
YOUR REACTION?
>> THE FIRST THING IS IF THE
REPORT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF, WHY
NOT DO A PRESS CONFERENCE?
AND IN THE 9 MINUTES AND NINE
SECONDS, WE LEARNED THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION AND NO OBSTRUCTION
AFTER 22 MONTHS, 19 LAWYERS, 500
WITNESSES, 2800 SUBPOENAS, IT
WAS THE SAME DARN CONCLUSION SO
THAT TO ME WAS A BIG TAKE AWAY.
IF THE REPORT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF,
WHY DID YOU DO A NINE MINUTE
92ND PRESS CONFERENCE?
>> Sean: MAY BE I READ TOO
MANY OF THE CLOSED-DOOR
TESTIMONY TO SEE WHAT PEOPLE
LIKE YOURSELF AND MARK MEADOWS
WERE DOING BEHIND THE SCENES.
NOW CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS
RELEASED THE CLOSED-DOOR
TESTIMONY.
THE QUESTION THAT YOU AND OTHERS
WOULD ASK, THEY WERE POIGNANT
AND RELEVANT AND I GOT TO THE
FACTS.
I DON'T THINK BOB MUELLER WOULD
WANT TO GO BEFORE YOU.
AND HE DIDN'T SEEM TOO
INTERESTED IN A RUSSIAN DOSSIER,
THAT WAS FULL OF LIES AND
DISSEMINATED BY THE PUBLIC TO
LEAKS IN THE PRESS.
I LIKE THOSE ANSWERS.
>> I THINK THERE WERE THREE
TAKEAWAYS FROM TODAY.
AND THIRD, I THINK HE DOESN'T
WANT TO TESTIFY.
IT'S UP TO JERRY NADLER BUT
THERE ARE LOTS OF QUESTIONS TO
ASK AND THE KEY ONE WAS WHERE
YOU WERE JUST OUT.
THIS DOSSIER.
BEFORE THEY WENT TO THE PFIZER
REPORT, THEY WERE TALKING ALL
KINDS OF THINGS ABOUT THE AUTHOR
OF THAT DOSSIER, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
HE WAS DESPERATE TO STOP TRUMP
AND HE DIDN'T TELL THE COURT
THAT INFORMATION OR -- THOSE
WERE QUESTIONS.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO GET THE
ANSWERS.
THE ONE I KNOW BETWEEN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, MR. DURHAM
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND